very good and we are
live
so i would like to
welcome everyone
to what we're calling an expert webinar
it's actually going to be a more or less
a fireside chat
uh why your company needs a chief data
officer we have vijay rivendra
dr john is the ceo of livecore a
blackstone company
and a noted expert author in the field
and
he founded
startup data that matters
more than 20 years
business and product development
globally
using data analytics
using ai and ml
to
digital transformation for
companies and
full spectrum from the fortune 500
to startups and
he
is an expert at combining
new technologies like artificial
intelligence and machine learning
with data governments
to
create significant and meaningful
organization transformations so we're
very lucky to have
you here today
the reason we've
provided him is because as i will tell
you at the end of the
session
simply learn is putting together a chief
data officer
certification program with imperial
college of london so
we'll talk about that just a bit at the
very end but what we'd like to talk most
about
is
what
bj has to offer us
i'm going to run a quick poll so that he
has an appreciation for who's in our
audience today
i'd just like you to take a moment
to answer
what is your current job role
and we also asked how you're feeling
today it's something we've been asking
throughout the pandemic
as
lockdowns and surges and
relaxations and
work from home have all disrupted our
lives
so i get a
feeling for how people are holding up
so
we have about 10 seconds left on the
pull
and i will share with you
the poll result
so we have
a few people at the cxo level uh some
managers
and some data professionals and then a
whole lot of people in other job
categories
so
talking i think
towards people who are interested in
what is a cdo and
whether that's a
path for
them personally so
let me
kick off the conversation with with you
uh vj uh first off
tell us a little bit more about
yourselves that i didn't cover in the
introduction
thank you stuart um can you hear me okay
yeah you're coming in fine
wonderful well good morning good
afternoon and good evening to everybody
um
um i think uh stuart you did a beautiful
uh introduction there so nothing huge
hugely to add i think the only thing i'd
say is you know my career in data has
been more accidental than uh then
channeled in some way just fell in and
loved data and
just managed to be lucky enough to kind
of you know go through the many
disciplines within data itself um
so
nothing much to add there
should we jump straight in
sure so uh
i think the fundamental question first
is what is a chief data officer
it sounds like it should be
self-explanatory
but it really isn't is it
no i think um
i think you're right you know the
the abbreviations of these most people
will know a cdo really translates to a
chief data officer
um but actually you know there are many
many articles out there
that really refer to the ambiguity of
the role itself
um i'm going to give you two that i
think is fairly popular
um joe bennett
wrote an article in gartner you know
stating that only 50 percent of cdos are
poised for success
um and and then there's another harvard
business review article by thomas
davenport randy bean and josh king
that really reiterated the importance of
defining this role clearly um you know
to avoid these short ten years within
chief beta officers itself i i think i
mean if you if you read a lot of the
stuff and actually if you go through
some of the careers or talk to people in
the industry
you know there's a lot of different uh
inclinations you can have right data is
so common and it's used throughout the
business
um so it could mean many thing and
everything and and even different people
recruiting for chief data officers
will probably have a slightly different
interpretation of what they're looking
for
especially in relation to where the
business maturity is
but i mean to come full circle back
a high level description of a chief data
officer is really someone who helps an
organization basically get right data
right time to the right person so simple
as that driving actionable insights and
then really kind of achieving your
business outcomes through that
um that's interesting it's reminiscent
of a a principle in medicine um
there's something called the five rights
of of medication
the right drug in the right dose at the
right time to the right patient uh the
right delivery method
so you talk about the three rights of
chief data officer uh duties that's
um
that's a great
way to organize that thought
so as you mentioned there's a lot of
people out recruiting
the fine chief data officers for their
companies
but
what motivates that why does a company
need a chief data officer what
what the companies perceive as that need
um i think you know
um
data is growing at such a rapid pace
right i think um
i'm gonna keep the audience kind of also
posting questions here so i'd love to
kind of think about
you know what the audience thinks in in
2021 alone how much data did we actually
create globally right
um i'm not sure if you're familiar with
it with the measurement of a zettabyte
um
but you know we've created something
like 60 to 80 zettabytes of data and
actually the the funny thing is that not
all of that is new data
um the the magnitude of copies of data
is also growing at an alarming
rate
and that's got a lot of pre you know um
impacts on the side right the more data
disperses it creates more data it also
creates a lot of noise
um and with this noise um comes you know
difficulty to actually translate and
understand that and link all the pieces
together and kind of connect back and
and and get meaningful you know actions
out of cell
a cheap data officer works a lot with
multiple areas of the business right
data is going to be critical for
in every function whether you're in
finance risk management marketing every
single function will have people who are
playing with data or interpreting data
and to to run their business
the challenge is really kind of getting
all of these areas to start working
together and how do you link up across
the enterprise itself and there's a real
a juggling um
skill set that you kind of need
to bring all of the parties together
especially in today's world where things
are pretty fluid you know people can go
out and and spin off technology is
pretty easy and fast you can go on the
cloud you can turn things on and it's
great that everybody's innovating at
such a a great pace
and and because of that
um you know we create more data
so unlike you know people refer to data
as the new oil
um you know oil depletes over time right
but but with data the the more you touch
it the more you create so it's really
important for someone who can kind of
you know make sense of all of this
information and see how the enterprise
actually you know benefits uh from from
the joint knowledge
okay
um
so can you we talked about some of the
ambiguities within the role
of acedia
can you comment a little bit about
what the different
roles within that those duties are
what
paths a ceo has to wear in the course of
performing those duties
sure i think um and on the broad on on
the broad scale
um
i would say a cdo wears
you know has got four dimensions four
hats on and and you know different i'll
cover some articles and other uh
comments on on on the different hats but
i think they fall into these four
categories
uh the first one is you know you're
gonna be
you gotta have a good balance between
what i would call a defensive strategy
and an offensive strategy and a
defensive strategy is more around
being your data defender for your firm
right whether you're talking about
regulations about data ethics data
privacy but you're really there for your
clients and your customers and you're
you're doing the right thing right
regulations and stuff comes comes up to
kind of make sure we do the right thing
but if you're doing the right thing in
the first place so you're really playing
that data defensive role
on the offensive side you know you're
really trying to optimize your business
drive revenue or helping your business
win more business right with more
clients with more customers and so
that's one angle and
some of them you know you got to get the
balance right and also it changes over
time on you know where where you slunt
the the other two dimensions that
achieve that officer
has to juggle is between tactical and
strategic initiatives you know a
tactical initiative could be just
running your business as as usual right
standard business operations you could
be in the marketing department
generating campaigns you know to acquire
new customers right or you all prospects
um that is in every department you would
have activities like that and and they
need data help
because you have to connect information
from many different systems and
sometimes these systems don't talk to
each other so you have to try and figure
out how to connect uh information so
clients or you know things together
on the other angle you can't be very
focused on just the tactical things you
also start to think about what are the
strategic things i need to put in place
number one to take advantage of the data
that you're getting because
you're looking at things at an
enterprise level you know you get new
opportunities new products that you can
actually develop or new services
um
and and even you know it's it's quite
popular now more and more companies are
actually also monetizing the data
directly you know so you can monetize
their data by selling more and being
more optimal but you you know you can
also create lots of benchmarks that and
roll up at a higher level that you can
sell for other people to to learn on
right so getting the balance between
tactical initiative and strategic
initiatives uh are very very key now
an important part although that these
are four dimensions
achieve the data officer has got to be
an excellent communicator because you
can't do them all in one go so you got
to be really good with um really
linking communicating with people and
people can be every anyone in your team
as well as your stakeholders and you got
to balance that with the business itself
because your business has again operates
in different business lines different
geographies so you got to get a good
handle on that and at the same time you
have to be pretty well worse and on
technology on what what do you have what
are the tool sets do you have at hand so
that you can help you execute the things
that that that you have to do
i think i'd only add two more things to
that stuart is
there's two articles
um one by thomas davenport brandy bean
who talked about seven hats of uh of
chief data officer it's kind of similar
but maybe in a broader grouping and they
talk about
you know um a chief data officer plays
the classic you know
data architect role to a data
entrepreneur role data defender role uh
he becomes the the leader of you know
all the data management and data
analytics type activities in the company
and another one that i really like is uh
deloitte's released an article
um talking about the four faces of cdo
and they describe it as a catalyst
to a strategist to a technologist and an
operator and a catalyst could be
you know anything from innovating change
management talent management
strategists can be someone who's really
good at focusing on value and demand um
technologies is all about architecture a
solution delivery and an operator can be
all about operating performance
governance and
shared service
okay so those are all um
i mean that's several different models
for
looking at the the different dimensions
of a
cdo and all of them are
useful um i'd like to encourage our
audience to answer questions
uh for vj into the
uh
q a box
within webex
if you're
on our streaming with the youtube or
linkedin you can put questions into the
comments and we should be able to
capture some of those
and
um
so
when you mentioned strategists you
mentioned a couple of aspects one of
them is
the business strategy for
creating new revenue streams and
attracting new customers but what about
the
the data strategy what are what is your
view on
how a chief data officer takes
responsibility for
the
management nurturing protection
of
the organization's data and and
understanding how it's going to be used
to support the goals of that
organization
um
i have a simple formula that i i tend to
follow when trying to develop a data
strategy um and really it has three
components to it right the first one is
um every strategy starts with some kind
of hypothesis a business thesis which
have you know assumptions to it
um that's really important to get a hold
on um you know because whatever you
develop from a data strategy or
technology strategy has to kind of
support that
the second component that i see is super
important is
what is the firm's kind of risk or
change appetite
um
the reason that's important is not
everything can be done in day one some
things will take longer than others
and that will give you a time dimension
on how to build out you know over time
how you're going to start to build a
data driven culture so those two things
are really helpful because you have to
kind of latch on to that it has to marry
to those to then build a data strategy
that you can start to structure in terms
of
what am i going to do to optimize the
business and optimize the business can
often be tackled by
mapping them to a customer life cycle
or a client life cycle
and then another part of it could be
also you know businesses diversifying
the business right you know they're
diversifying whether it's different
geography or different asset classes
you can then kind of form data groups
and the capabilities to kind of support
that
and out of that you know you can decide
on what are the services that you're
going to provide or products that you're
going to build and that will inform
the type of structures that you have to
put in in all the different practices
that we have whether it's data
management and
data engineers data architects you can
kind of you know flush it out but it
really has to key from from the hype
business hypothesis itself
i think um one the third element which
is absolutely critical for a data
strategy is a strategy is only good if
you can actually execute it
so if you don't have an arm that's
capable of executing uh the strategy
you kind of fall short very quickly you
know so i call it the data portfolio
management
it's basically like a air traffic
controllers
and just to give you some of my
experience um throughout my 20-plus
years of career and data
you will
being in the data world you know you
will never be short of work that's
always plenty of things to do and and
you know you will never have enough
resources to do them because the more
you open doors the more doors that
you're gonna open further
it's also important to know what you
shouldn't be doing or what you should
park
um versus the things that you should
focus on right so
the data portfolio management is a
really important function because
you need to be able to juggle and give
teams the independence to kind of work
in independence independently uh
you know a sign of this you tend to get
it sometimes you go into some firms with
initiatives for every single thing you
have to get 20 30 people meeting
together it really starts to get you
being very sluggish
um at the same time you just need to
have some frameworks to keep all these
different teams aligned to some
framework for data some elements you
can't go too far straight so that you
can kind of get
you can connect the information together
and really the data portfolio management
really should be built around you know
value focus and whatever that means and
defining those success kpis
are
are very very uh
super important
it's important to understand that
um you know the markets change very
quickly right nobody predicted you know
the world that we're in over the last
two and a half years it kind of dawned
on us very quickly
so you know i think that's a that
definitely needs you know the need to
kind of stay flexible but at the same
time you know controlling the data
portfolios and people doing the work you
need to kind of get some level of
consistency if it's haphazard and ad hoc
it it becomes very sluggish over time
and it's really hard to kind of keep
talent right so when you're when you're
driving business strategies great to
kind of keep the stakeholders and
business leaders aligned and trying to
achieve the goal but without the people
who are doing the work and you can't
keep them focused and aligned to the
purpose
you know you're not going to be able to
deliver those those strategies
okay
we have a question from the audience by
the way that is
kind of fundamental and it gets back to
i think the first question i asked which
is
nabil asks what's the difference between
a chief information officer
and a chief data officer
that's a that's a excellent excellent
question you know i think
in many organizations
the chief data officer role often is
started off or played by the chief
information officer
that is quite common they do wear the
data hat on
they probably play more of the
technologist role
in there
even the chief the chief information
officer
role has been around a little bit longer
than the chief data officer so it's a
little bit more mature
even the cio role has evolved
tremendously over the last i'd say 15
years or so
the remit is pretty broad
so i what i would say is
you know
it's really a question of focus the area
is so broad that you kind of need people
to focus on these areas because the cio
role is very very broad especially when
you're looking at all the application
landscape technology all the digital
solutions and stuff typically a chief
data officer partners a cio very very
closely
so they complement each other and i
think when people are smaller
it's quite natural to see a cdo role
start with the cio and branch out later
it also sometimes punches out with you
know it's quite common to see chief data
officer role sitting within a
cfo
or a chief operating officer too
yeah i mean the
the concept is that that data is the
lifeblood of the organization and
essential to its operations and then you
have to decide
who really is
the cxo and responsible for
the
operation of the company does the cdo
report to the
chief operating officer because it's an
operational issue or those two financial
officer because
financial officer is responsible for all
of the
compilation of data into the financial
status of the company
or the
chief executive officer because
the cdo role is
important enough in that company to
be on a peer with the ceo and the cfo so
a lot of different and it's important
i think that's spot-on stupid i mean the
thing is data is in the intersection of
so many things
and it really comes down i i would look
at it as who can create the most focus
to achieve the things in income
combination right so it's really
important for a cdo to work with all of
those above i mean you could question
the same of what's the difference
between a cio and a chief technology
officer and a chief digital officer i
think a lot of these roles are all
coming up because
the areas are so broad that they're
trying to create focus
in those specific areas so i would worry
less about what each titles mean because
you know people have titles but
sometimes you know your role might not
even uh do anything with the title right
right right
i would focus very much on
uh partnering with the people around you
and making sure that you know incoming
you know combinedly as a team you can
kind of achieve and uh the things that
you're trying to achieve together
so when you look at
what you need to build
the data strategy for the company
um
what are the things that what are the
other components or tools
or people that the
cdo has to draw upon pull into that that
process
um
great question i mean i think we touched
on the first three components already
you know having a business hypothesis
the investment thesis i call it uh the
change strategy within that uh
understanding the risk appetite and the
change appetite
we talked a little bit about the data
portfolio management itself
now those are all very different and
different companies are in different
parts of their journey so it's really
important for
anyone who's thinking of a career as a
chief data officer
to really understand where the business
actually is because you might start and
end in different places
but one area that i always kind of think
that you can get ahead of the curve a
little bit is i call it the data 101
there are five important things that i
often kind of think i keep it in my back
pocket
and they can be applied to many
different scenarios just to accelerate
you know some of the
the implementation of data and providing
people options right
number one
it's uh i mean if you look at jobs right
now
data engineers or data scientists i mean
these roles are everywhere right now you
know
they i think repeatedly year over year
they're coming up as the number one to
three you know highest volume jobs out
there right there's just so many of them
and it's so hard to find that so
really important to a lot of this is
developing a talent strategy
uh data teams you know maybe 20 years
ago you might find data teams a team of
four or five people within a small
function
you know now you're kind of talking
about 200 400 people you know
in data organization you and really when
you have that kind of scale
and the complexity whether someone's an
architect or a data governance person or
a data management person
they really want to know how do they
develop their careers whether it's
within their vertical their disciplines
how do they go across how does an
engineer go across to kind of lead data
products for example you know um you
really have to build and think about
talent strategies you know i think
there are barriers of doing this is is a
lot easier now
i think it's really important with you
know a lot of the online courses right
now i mean you guys can simply learn do
a lot of courses uh but also not only
just individual courses i think it's
important to kind of create mappings of
how people can advance in their careers
and test out some of all of these
different roles and develop over a
longer term right so that talent
strategy is really really important
um i actually wrote an article on on
linkedin about you know having
six um career notes stars uh learning is
is one of those it's important but it's
also important to kind of give people
the flexibility right to to learn uh
different aspects of data
um
and experience that that journey i think
one thing important to teach about you
know to teach data folks is the art of
learning um 20 years ago you know a
typical job would have you know a skill
set in one programming languages and
stuff
nowadays we wouldn't hire somebody who's
not versatile in jumping between two or
three different languages two or three
different platforms because
what we're testing for people to know is
their agility to change and to adapt to
change and their their
um their ambition and willingness to
learn because technology is just moving
at such a pace that you can't stick to
just one thing right it's adaptability
i i think one more thing uh two more
things really i think on the talent
strategy you got to really think about
recognition kind of linking up that you
know um learning experience in career
development to recognition and the final
thing is
you know
data people have got a lot to say right
uh building their brands out digitally
it's really useful so that the data
folks become your ambassadors of your
company you know products and and
services on its own right it's really
important to think about those those six
node stars um
the second one sorry that was a long
long-winded thing on challenge but
talent's quite close to me because
it's critical i mean it's
the
the at the fundamental level a
company is basically the reason in fact
the word company
refers to the group of people that
execute its
operations and strategy so
yeah talent is critical so don't
apologize for that
especially in today's market where
you know your talent has you know
multiple different um options available
because the demand is so high
um
so you know paying real attention to
that is it's critical i think the next
thing i would say is how do you organize
yourself
this is a topic um you know it's pretty
confusing sometimes on how do you
structure your data teams right do you
structure them by
vertical disciplines
do you structure if you have if you're
spread across multiple countries do you
have teams across multiple countries who
do you centralize you know federated or
not
that is you know there's no right or
wrong answer to be honest for those it
really depends on the maturity of the
business itself but it's good to know um
all of the different options and the
plus and minuses of those
because they can help you accelerate
what you're trying to achieve so
structure is quite key
um everything can't be centralized so
it's always typically a hybrid
but it's knowing what to focus centrally
versus decentralizing
uh that's also
go ahead sorry didn't mean that
to say you talk about
structure and centralization it does
trigger the thought about
how you have to structure
data protection because of the
the
what's called the threat surface
as
more and more of the organization
becomes
points as sources for data they also
become points of vulnerabilities for
data breaches so
um
just wanted to add that in
completely i mean i i think when you
look at
um the whole topic around data privacy
data protection
it's so different in each count
countries right now right so it's
important to take in not only from an
architectural view but also from a
former people uh just to keep up with
all the things that are going on locally
i think the next thing that's uh really
good to have um is a good understanding
of what's out there in terms of a modern
modern data platform um you know
a data guy doesn't have much to do if
you don't give him a modern data
platform that's his uh you know is his
toolkit
and uh i think
data platforms have come a long long way
in the last you know 10 years
um
there are many many things out there
that you can choose
a combination of different things uh the
flexibility is just amazing right now
how you can just turn on and off and try
different things without having to plan
it for five years and so on right even
from a capacity stuff so not only
talking about if you're thinking of cost
savings to move to the cloud but you
know the flexibility is is so great
right and also you won't be able to
attract great talent
if you're not moving to modern data
platforms because people don't want to
be joining careers and go obsolete in
terms of their skill sets
um
i
actually wrote an article about you know
six things that you can you can think
about right uh when you're thinking of a
modern platform um i'll just read out
the sakes but you know you should think
cloud first
uh whenever you think about choosing a
platform lead with speed and timeliness
of data because data pipelines is one of
the biggest reasons or you know reasons
to slow down your executing a ability
and when you're
shopping around you know make sure that
you get people to demonstrate the the
flexibility of the the product itself
right because
people always kind of say rubbish and
rubbish out
but the reality is that you can't spend
time governing everything and correcting
everything
uh before you drive inside right the key
is
sometimes you just have got limited time
to make the best decision on the data
that you have
now sometimes you can't make a mistake
and it has to be super accurate but in
knowing that you can do both it's really
key so you know things like what can you
access can you access the data link
directly what are the tool sets is all
really important to understand
i think the fourth thing i would say is
you can't really develop data platforms
anymore as a
project right like a one-off project
that you just bolt on
you really got to think about your data
platform as a product as a welcoming
product because you're really trying to
democratize data today and get you're
getting the whole firm to be data
scientists right in in 10 15 years time
you know there's gonna be everybody who
just knows how to code i mean my six my
son at the age of six was already
programming in in scratch and things
like that right
so
personalizing the experience of using
your platform is super key so if you're
building something in-house
you really have to get that ux ui
experience right so someone has a you
know it shouldn't be different to them
going out and buying a third-party
product in terms of how they navigate
your platform
um the the last two items are built
around uh transparency around risks so i
think you touched on it earlier about
privacy confidentiality security all of
those are super key
good to know what the platforms already
have addressed that you can use
um
and then continuous learning you know
about your users be moniquely focused on
who's using the platform where
um you know you have a lot of ml engines
you know in the background that tells
you
which tables people are using in fact
you even have things that can tell you
how to join information better when they
don't have you know good uh structured
ways of joining things together
yeah so those are things that i would
say from a modern data platform uh as a
super key
i think just to find uh close up the
last two items is
one is getting a good understanding of
how data and business information
architecture links up so good knowledge
of that is important and i think finally
which is a huge topic is data governance
um
you know we touched on it a little bit
earlier about privacy about
confidentiality and so on but
often this it should come out in your
business strategy
but often they come out more organically
when you're running a company because a
new regulation has kind of come out
but it's good to be on the forefront of
these things now if you're constantly
thinking about the right thing to do
by your customers you should capture
most of these things
um
i have a question
about
how someone pursues this type of career
path does
does a cdo by definition have to be
a
a data scientist
and
what are the other aspects
of
skills knowledge aptitudes that
someone needs to have in order to pursue
this your role from a complete business
path so not from a technology kind of
coder
um
i mean if i shared my experience you
know my first part of my career i was a
data geek you know i was geeking out
with building school cards
uh building warehouses and stuff and i
had for lots of fun with that
you know i do think that it's important
to go through that pain just to
understand some of the challenges so you
can appreciate it right it's really
important you don't have to do it
hands-on to know that it's not difficult
um but i think it gives you a sense of
appreciation i've also seen chief data
officers coming from a program
perspective right there's people who
lead large practices
whether it's offshore practices like
data capabilities
uh you have quite a few of these i've
seen cdo's come in from that because
they're managing teams who are doing
this stuff
so over time they appreciate you know
elements of it and then finally i think
maybe less but i also see
some business folks you know kind of
moving into the the cdo role right i
think
my encouragement to people is
um whatever that interest you um you
know do that but do that well
um and then expand you know as you you
go along i never planned to be a chief
data officer that's not what i was
planning for
i i i was just focused on problems that
i love to solve
um and i just got my head down and did
it did a really good job with most of
those
and then and learned the things you know
that are complementary alongside but one
of the important things is to keep your
mind focused on what are you what is the
purpose what is the big thing that
you're trying to do
rather than getting too
uh focused on a particular tech or
routine that you're trying to develop so
keep your head above to look at you know
the broader picture constantly
um
we have a question from some kuntala
who asks um
with
it relates to the point you made about
agility
broader list of data analytics tools
growing
what is the best way for a cdo to keep
track and keep an overview of
the state of the technology and the
tools out there
what what
strategy do you use for keeping on top
of that
i you know i try not to create a
bottleneck um just by a cdo
we really encourage everyone in the firm
to kind of really expand and know be
close to what's kind of happening out
there and we create lots of innovation
activities within our organization so
people are constantly experimenting you
know there's a fine balance in terms of
you know you doing um completely
innovative innovation type pocs a proof
of concepts
but you know
this kind of gives people career
satisfaction too to be constantly things
are changing really quickly
so i would use the organization under me
to kind of drive that and get and i
learn from the people you know you can
learn in so many ways right so
it's it's really important to keep your
eye open on what's happening around
and and constantly experimenting with
new
new things out there
okay
um
that's always
good advice and and there are also
tools and courses that you can use to
when you come across a tool that you
want to know more about there's usually
a
course or training that you can get to
familiarize yourself
to whatever degree whether you want to
be just
basically familiar with what it does
or whether you want to become an actual
practitioner using that tool so
um i mean i i think what we tend to do
is most of these areas will give people
in the modern platform right modern day
platform
you typically have two or three already
there made available for people to use
and you develop courses
um
and and training because
you're going to be measuring adoption
for most of the things that you release
so it's important you know people learn
but i tend to not just restrict them to
those right they might start with those
two or three that we choose
um but over time that list needs to also
evolve you know so you use the broader
network of people to kind of keep you
informed
right and then it gets back to your
point about your history as a data geek
where if you've got people working for
you who have that kind of
uh passion
for playing with data and
looking at new tools for playing with it
in different ways
and like one of them comes to you and
says
i found this really great new tool that
here's what it can do for us that we
aren't doing now or that it's taking us
ten steps to do what this will do and
two
um
that's that's one of the clear pathways
that organizations find out about and
adopt new tools right completely and i
think you know going full circle to
something i said in the beginning right
when you get when you take your job it's
important to know where is the business
maturity of the company itself
you might be joining a huge company
that's organically grown and you know
they're looking to cut cost and so it's
a pure cost cutting you know i need to
streamline all my operations and stuff
and that might be the goal temporarily
even you know
so in those kind of scenarios you might
find yourself more restricted to open up
those so it's really important to do
your research on the companies you're
joining to see you know what exactly are
the approach i mean everybody cuts costs
don't don't don't get me wrong you're
always trying to keep your operations
optimal
but you know you can get a gauge whether
companies in growth mode or not
uh nabil had a question um which was in
the case of a data breach what is
you know what does the cdo
do and i think that that boils you know
that
you can explore uh vj into both
what do you do in advance to protect the
data
against breach and then what
does the cdo and his organization
do
to
respond to a breach
yeah i think um the first thing is if if
you're thinking about a breach when the
breach has already happened you're
already in trouble before you know um
you'll be in trouble right i think
most of those things uh
you've got to prepare for these things
well in advance way in advance so when
you're kind of even thinking of
solutions you're thinking of
architecture security is injected into
every single product or services
right you do the assessment and not only
the things that you are developing even
if you're using third parties to kind of
pass on information
it is our response it's the chief data
officer's responsibility
you know to kind of make sure that the
third party are operating in
in the right mannerism right because you
have the right agreements in place
and um you know just because somebody
else is responsible to carry out
managing your customers data it doesn't
take away the accountability aspects of
that so i think the key there is
make sure the assessments are done
and make sure however perfect you think
you are
you have a process developed on how to
identify it and what is your mitigation
response structure right i think
developing those and making sure people
are on point
to know that that is super important is
is really really key okay excellent
um i'm looking at the
let's see if there's
we had a couple of questions about the
articles
that you mentioned and also one question
that came in about
any book recommendations you might have
so
when you go back to the the
articles you mentioned um
the one in gartner and the other
by davenport at all joe bennett and
gartner what what is the title of joe
bennett's article
do you recall i
believe is the seven
uh hats you know i could um
they're all of them are on my linkedin
profiles but we could also send out the
articles afterwards to to to the folks
but most of the articles go to my
linkedin profile
they should have references to those
and i happen to have your linkedin
profile
link here so i'm going to put that in
the chat right now
for all the attendees
for their reference reach out to you
and that's in the chat now um
be able to
click on that and get right to
vj's linkedin page um
we have one and it was not there anyone
interested um we could circulate it
maybe afterwards or find a way to kind
of or reach out to me separately too
yeah certainly we send a follow-up email
after these sessions
and we'll be sending out a link to the
recording and if you have other links
that you want me to include
pass those to me vijay and i will put
those into the follow-up email um
will it be hard
acacia asks
is this something
you mentioned people can can come from
other backgrounds
is this hard for somebody who's never
studied the data
how long would it take for somebody to
make that kind of a career pivot
um i don't think it's hard at all in
fact more and more companies and now
this is becoming a popular trend
companies are actually quite open to
take um you know people who have focused
on programming skills
uh even without a degree you know that's
becoming quite an increasing trend
and you have courses that you can learn
these subjects within anything from six
months to nine months to learn how to
code different aspects and get an
overview of different um areas of data
um you guys simplylearn does a lot of
those courses too
and so it's not i don't think it's
difficult to do but i would say that
typically when someone's looking for a
data science or data engineer if you
don't have coding experience
um a couple of them
you know you the cv doesn't go much
further than that right so i don't think
it's difficult to learn it's very
logical like i said my son is already
learning it at the age of six
so i think as long as you're open to
learning it's it's not difficult it's
actually quite logical
very good i think that's pretty much
takes us to the end of our conversation
and i wanted to
thank
you for being here vijay
um we have a couple of things that we'd
like to say
to uh our audience so let me
go ahead and put up
this powerpoint
again
first off again here's uh vijay's
linkedin that's in the chat so you can
connect with him directly
and i want to thank you again for being
here um
i want to mention a program that simply
learn is developing and this program is
with the imperial college of london
it is a program that
will qualify people
to succeed as
a chief data officer
it's an online program with
online live at virtual classrooms
i'm going to send out
on the chat a
link to a quick survey about the program
to help you
gauge your interest and help us gauge
interest from the audience
so if you would
click on that and fill in the form after
you finish here in the next couple of
minutes but
you can also
email practice
practice happens to be on the call with
us so if you'd like to introduce
yourself pratik and mention
a little bit more about this program
please do
unmute yourself
and i'm looking to see if
yeah go ahead please
we're not hearing you i think you might
need to look at your uh
webex voice settings
i want to go to the webex audio settings
and select the correct microphone and
speaker
all right i think he's he's having
technical difficulties so
um
i think i think he's having some issues
with his mic
so firstly i'd like to thank vijay for
this wonderful session i think it was
very insightful and uh i think
i'm sure the audience would also agree
that this has been an extremely fruitful
session and uh
we got to learn a lot around
the responsibilities the hats to wear
and you know how to strategize the
various aspects related to strategizing
uh you know your data strategy uh
you know as a chief data officer so
thank you vijay for that uh
it was a pleasure having you here
uh
also uh i mean uh i just wanted
everybody to know that simply learn has
actually partnered with imperial college
london and we'll soon be launching uh
achieve data and analytics or officer
program with them
uh so this would be a you know close to
around three to four month program uh
uh wherein uh we would have both
asynchronous sessions as well as live
virtual classroom sessions delivered by
imperial faculty and we will be touching
around various aspects related to the
chief data officer
uh you know cheap the the chief data
officer role uh so we'll be touching
around aspects like data science uh
you know uh
how to monetize data how how can you
create a data driven digital
transformation strategy
aspects related to data privacy ethics
governance and so on
so as to what mentioned we've actually
put in a link to a survey uh which we
would be extremely delighted if you
could fill that up for us because that
would actually help us
gauge what are the aspects or what are
the key areas that you would want us to
focus while you know developing this
program
uh and so that we can you know create
the best for for everyone who's
interested in it
so yeah that's that's all about from my
end
all right thank you so much
those uh links are in the chat including
a link to
patrick patra's email uh to stay
informed and to the survey
that i've enough just spoke about so
with that i'm going to say that we have
a next
uh webinar
uh a week from
thursday which is week from tomorrow um
design thinking for digital
transformation with uh maryam darbegi
it's a conversation between
uh maryam who is the founder of
innovation bazaar an expert on
design thinking and sumiya biswas who is
simplyland's director of design
and it'll be a
fireside chat similar to today's uh
between
two experts in design thinking so i
highly recommend that that'll be next
thursday march 31st i am putting into
the chat again
the information about that
and you'll be able to click that link
and register
have a lot of resources for you we'll
also be sending out follow-up emails
tomorrow
with a number of these links
and information that vj had mentioned in
this presentation so
uh we invite you to continue to
follow us on facebook and twitter at
simplylearn and on linkedin
our company link is simply learn
we look forward to seeing you at future
webinars we also look forward to
welcoming you into the simply learn
learning community and with that uh
we've completed our session for today
thank you all for being here
thank you so much everyone and thanks a
lot vijay and stuart for you know uh
organizing this session and
letting everybody understand how
important the cdo rule is thank you so
much
you